oh well the street couldn't last forever
Saigon invasion the spoiler free version
is this is the first episode to let me
down so far this particular series
there's a bunch of asterisks after that
but I can't really explain those without
getting into spoilers so we'll do that
right now
from the get-go there was a lot I really
liked about this episode I mean I love
the fact that we've got Osgood back I
mean who was not thrilled when that
showed up as the next time on Doctor Who
back at the last episode and I think the
way to bring her back that's wonderful
that's clever and I like that they are
finding a way to not firmly answer if
she is the human or the Zygon I'm
inclined to think she's the human
because we saw her use the inhaler but
again the whole thing that they're going
with she's kind of part Saigon kind of
part not because the rules have changed
a little bit it's it still could go
either way or maybe it truly does not
matter I like the whole idea of just
this little splinter group of the Zygons
going rogue ages this is very clearly
dealing with sort of Islamic terrorists
and dealing with that look this is a
radicalized group but you have to be
careful with how you deal with them
because if you deal with them the wrong
way other people within sort of that
general group are gonna feel just as
angry as they aren't they or numbers
will grow so I'd like that it was sort
of addressing that but as much as the
foundational idea of this episode is
good and solid that the execution of it
is not great I'm getting increasingly
irritated with the character of Kate
Stewart I really liked her in all of her
appearances prior to this series we saw
her a couple of episodes ago and she
wasn't great in her peers there but it
was brief and I thought I was prepared
to brush it off but she's just crap in
this episode she just seems extremely
not good at her job and I mean
regardless of whether she's being more
aggressive than maybe the doctor but
like she has to be competent at what she
does and she doesn't come off as
competent in this episode at all I don't
like that the episode is sort of playing
fast and loose with the rules of how as
I gone
works and what it is that they do and
how they do it I'm not against changing
the way that certain alien races work I
think that's a nice way to revitalize it
but remember the Zaycon this is only
their third appearance yes there are
classic era villain but they only have
one appearance in the classic era they
showed up in the 50th anniversary this
is only the third time we've seen them
you can't tell me that you've exhausted
all the possibilities with the way that
they were already working that it was
necessary to change how they function
and it also annoys me because the show
just keeps sort of self contradicting
itself too because Osgood says well they
don't have to keep the people that
they're impersonating alive anymore is
like okay then why is Clara still alive
I mean I know her duplicate said she's
dead at the end of the episode which I
also don't believe but we saw her body
being kept and why would they keep her
alive when they're killing so many other
people indiscriminately I had hoped that
maybe it would turn out that they're
only killing where necessary and there
being much more surgical and they're not
being sort of indiscriminate with the
humans that they're taking out but
they're coming across as really
indiscriminate so why didn't they kill
Clara what would be the reason to keep
her alive just so we could have that
reveal that the car we've been farming
was as I got which was a well-executed
reveal I will give props to that but
once I actually started thinking about
it going but they don't need to keep her
alive so why is she alive and there's
nothing Boltz logistical moments and
scenes that just don't work that the
whole thing with the unit team that gets
food because the the Zygons
impersonating the guys mother and the
commanders all no no go in and then she
runs around this corner this is after
it's established that she's like several
buildings back we see her run backwards
around this corner not in the direction
that she'd been looking when she was
telling them what to do we see her shoot
a Dora barge in and there's all these
you know remains of bodies of what's
left when Zygons do their thing but
she's like they killed my men but they
establish the geography really really
poorly because i rewatch that scene a
couple times and it doesn't look like
she's going in the building they just
went into the
geography is a mess and it made the
whole thing confusing because it didn't
occur to me that she actually gone into
the same building except basically by
process of elimination it didn't make
sense otherwise what I'd done I also
don't like that because I I feel like it
was kind of over villainizing these
Zygons and I feel like there was
something more tense more dynamic they
didn't have to be the straight-up Bills
cuz I mean that the fact that they are
forced to walk around and are not
allowed to look like who they are they
they can't do it that's a fairly
legitimate grievance yes they're taking
it a bit too far but I feel like they've
been this conflict has been painted to
black and white and if you're telling me
this is a splinter group and you're not
showing me aside from just the two
commanders that get wiped out that there
are other Zygons who aren't a part of
this then I'm just kind of taking your
word for that and that's not good
storytelling either because you're
telling me but you're not showing me all
of that having been said it is possible
that this story will redeem itself
because two parters can be funny that
way
depending on how the second half goes
your opinion of the first half may go up
or it may go down as a result of how the
second half pays everything off the two
part of that I'm kind of reminded of is
the rebel flesh and the almost people
which was a Matt Smith story dealing
with this sort of semi sentient goo that
could sort of take the form of other
people so it was dealing with some of
the same stuff and I was not a big fan
of the first half of that two-parter but
I loved the second half in the way
wrapped everything up because it did not
go the way that I expected things do and
it turned out that there was just a lot
more going on under the surface than
what i given the episode credit for it
so that raised my estimation of the
first half because of how good the
execution of the second half was that is
possible that maybe that will happen
here that maybe the second half will
wrap things up so well that i will feel
better about this one there's still
gonna be problems with this though
because like I said there are just nuts
and bolts and bits about
characterization that are just aren't
great but if they can stick the landing
maybe my opinion of the overall story
will get improved but if you're asking
me today as it stands right now this is
the first stumble in this series which
is a shame because this has been a
phenomenal series so far so if you
caught the Saigon invasion what were
your thoughts on it whatever they were
comment down below and let's talk about
and until next time this council is
adjourned